bonjour à tous bonjour à tous vous avez
peut-être compris de quoi je vais vous
parler ce que je vais aborder durant
cette aide c'est se passe dans l'arène
du rap
vous savez cette cette musique parfois
décrite comme un comme une musique de
voyous comme une musique de faits divers
voire comme un effet de mode voué à
disparaître et bien oublié cette idée
oublier cette manière d'appréhender le
rap parce que je vous en parlais de
manière totalement différente
je vais vous parler du rap comme une
source d'inspiration avec un s je vais
vous parler de ces femmes et de ces
hommes qui composent le moins durable
donc les rappeurs mais également tous
ces acteurs du monde d'europe
les labels dans les médias etc les
rappeurs évidemment dans les outils
comme une source d'innovation une source
de créativité et comme des modèles
d'inspiration
mais avant de rentrer dans le dans le
vif du sujet tout d'abord quelques
petites définition au bout du moins
qu'est ce que l'europe leur a fait
partie d'un mouvement beaucoup plus
large qui s'appelle le hip hop apparu
dans les années 70 dans le bronx à new
york
le rap est donc apparu dans ce mouvement
aux côtés du deejaying dj en train de
manier les vinyles
de la break dance vous voyez ces
individus en train de tourner au sol
parfois on se demande ce qu'il fout du
graff ferait de graffitis du beatboxing
également la capacité à faire de la
musique avec sa bouche et enfin le rap
souvent on définit le rap comme une
poésie rythmée la définition une poésie
rythmée où un rappeur va poser un texte
que le texte soit écrit mémoriser ou
improviser sur une sur un beat ce qu'on
appelle une boucle mélodique invite
donnant lieu à une performance
artistique
historiquement donc le rap est apparue
années 70 80 les premiers groupes qui
ont fait connaître leurs apps peut-être
ça vous parlez
parce que ça vous parle ou celle ci peut
être un peu moins
bon les abouré ce le marseillais qui
j'étais obligé aura peut-être une petite
référence encore après la fonky family
on parle également y aurait tellement de
groupes à citer bien sûr bien sûr
donc là on a fait un voyage entre les
états unis et et le la france et
l'europe pour montrer que leur appétit
devenu une musique qui a voyagé et on
peut également citer cette chanson
jamais ça va donc depuis toutes ces
années leur a pas fait énormément de
chemin
on le retrouve partout que ce soit
évidemment sur internet sur le site de
partage de vidéos on le retrouve à la
radio à la télé on le retrouve dans les
défilés haute couture dans les défilés
sur le bitume aussi dans la rue le style
style hip hop style arabe
on le retrouve dans différentes sphères
on le retrouve dans les théâtres dans
les musées on le retrouve également dans
les slogans des manifestations
peut-être comme certains connaissaient
ch ici ou pnl
on le retrouve également dans les
colloques scientifiques je vous en
parlais donc le rap
une fois qu'on a dit tout cela on peut
se poser la question mais quand on s'y
intéresse vraiment à cette musique
cette musique de voyous qu'est ce que ça
peut réellement nous apprendre qu'est ce
que ça peut réellement nous inspirer
évidemment le rap a déjà été étudié des
études littéraires ont déjà eu lieu sur
la construction des phrases l'emploi des
figures de style des parallèles ayant
même été fait entre certains rappeurs et
certains poètes historiques tels
qu'apollinaire rimbaud céline donc le
rap a déjà été étudiée au niveau
littéraire au niveau de la science
politique ou de la sociologie le rap a
déjà été étudiée continuer à être
étudiés de manière très intéressante par
des chercheurs ces disciplines éclairant
le rôle du rap dans les discours au
niveau politique dans les rapports de
force dans la proche spécifique de la
société
mais les sciences de gestion les
sciences du management dont je suis
enseignant chercheur et accessoirement
fans de rap avant tout il faut le dire
faut bien l'avouer
très peu de recherches ont été ont été
menées vous voir quasiment aucune je
vais en parler autour du rap comme
source d'inspiration pour le monde de
l'entreprise pour le management
en d'autres termes comment peut-on
s'inspirer de cette musique qui remplit
les festivals qui remplit les et nick
aujourd'hui n'a plus un festival sans
une tête d'affiche des landes rappeur
plusieurs fêtes musique qui est selon le
snep syndicat national de l'édition
phonographique qui est la musique la
plus primée la plus populaire la plus
téléchargée la plus vendue qui trustent
le haut de toutes les tous les
classements notamment en france qui est
la musique la plus populaire en france
aujourd'hui
qu'est ce que des chercheurs en sciences
de gestion qui habituellement s'habitue
au monde de l'entreprise à l'action
collective organisée à la manière dont
on peut en mettre un peu mettre en place
de la communication du leadership des
stratégies de motivation qu'est ce qu'un
chercheur qui s'intéresse à sa va
pouvoir puiser dans le rap on se rend
compte que je tape tic a pas mal de
choses qui peuvent émerger
la prise de conscience il y en eu lieu
pour ma part à la lecture de ceux ayant
lieu à la lecture de cet ouvrage de jean
philippe denis qui s'appelle
introduction ou hip hop management
originales comme tout aussi original que
son auteur cette cet ouvrage a été pour
moi une prise de conscience comme quoi
il est possible d'aborder sérieusement
le rap au prisme des sciences de gestion
au prisme du management ensuite à une
deuxième prise de conscience où on s'est
rendu compte avec mes co auteur avec
j'ai rencontré des personnes comme moi
dans des profs en sciences de gestion
qui s'intéressait à cette thématique là
et on s'est dit mais mes co auteur
turgot gaillard léo denis pour les cités
on s'est intéressés on a eu l'occasion
de rentrer dans le cercle émission du
rappeur social très populaire sur
youtube qui nous a permis d'aller
présenter nos travaux qui font le pas le
le parallèle la passerelle plutôt entre
le monde du rap et le monde de
l'entreprise et donc à partir de là
c'est une double prise de conscience un
double temps où on s'est rendu compte
les gars il ya des choses à faire on est
fan de rap déjà on est prof un sens de
gestion et des profs en management
on peut aller puiser et on est légitime
pour aller voir
ce qui se passe dans ce secteur ce qui
se passe dans ce dans ce milieu rap
temps tant décriée parfois méconnus et
donc quand on a pris un peu de recul
en discutant on a analysé ans
apparaissait évident pour revenir au
plus ancien des rappeurs tels que jay-z
tels que dr dre le jour où ces rappeurs
se sont mis à faire autre chose que de
la musique
on est rentrés dans l'ère du management
on est rentrés dans l'ère de l'industrie
musicale d'un terrain qui est
potentiellement très intéressant pour
les chercheurs en sciences de gestion
quand j'ai dit a cité à une note
business men in business même bon
punchline comme on dit on croise
punchline après tueur de réaliser les
travaux
donc quand commencer on a commencé à
s'intéresser à ça c'est dit il ya des
choses à faire et à des choses à creuser
plus proche de nous un rappeur comme
booba on a rapidement cité tout à
l'heure peut-être que certains le
connaissent ici en train de taper avec
une bouteille de parfum je crois que
c'est ça mais c'est pas comme ça que
vous en parlez je vous annonçais un mec
comme ça qui arrive à créer un
écosystème autour de lui
ces labels ses marques de vêtements sa
marque de spiritueux son agence de
conseil
son agence de conseil il a créé et même
un des médias ses propres médias est ce
qu'il ya ce qu'on appelle un pied de nez
par rapport aux médias traditionnels
skyrock n'est pas licite et qu'ils ne
souhaitaient pas pendant une époque
passée ces morceaux magnifiques
il a créé son propre écosystème comme
dit souvent pour nous par nous on peut
citer d'autres exemples des rappeurs
comme fait annuler ce n'est pas la
programmation neurolinguistique 1 pour
ce qui
pernelle qui défie peace and love est
composé du des otaries cannabis qui ont
peut-être vous l'avez vu sorti leur
album ya à peu près un mois je crois -
quelque qui ont fait de la communication
sans communication qui refuse toute
interview qui ont créé la rareté
à l'instar désolé pour eux de mylène
farmer ou daft punk faut le dire pas sûr
qu'ils acceptent vraiment le parallèle
c'est un peu ils ont fait ils se sont
fait mettre de l'annoncé de la non
communication comme communication
comment faire parler d'eux sans accorder
d'interview en envoyant à la fameuse
semaine planète rap qui est couru
partout les rappeurs tout le monde
souhaite absolument être présent dans
cette fabuleuse émission qui est un
formidable tremplin pour un succès
commercial il envoyer un singe les
représenter à tenter
ce groupe qui est disruptif parle en ces
termes la disruption en tant que prof de
gestion il ya un terme qui est super à
la mode il ya des tendances comme ça le
terme disruption on l'entend partout on
le voit partout
par contre ces mecs là je pense qu'il
incarne vraiment la disruption par
rapport à un marché
l'acca les voix si je demande quel est
votre représentation des rappeurs
casquette à l'envers
baghi pnl c'est plutôt défrisage tenues
moulantes et voilà ils sont en
descriptions leur musique hyper planante
est en décalage par rapport à ce qui se
fait le fait d'avoir quand même j'ai pas
si vous avez bien lu sur la photo
râpez tourner un clip au sommet de la
tour eiffel sans trucage
il aurait eu l'accord et même pour la
petite anecdote ce que j'ai appris a pas
longtemps
le représentant du de la société
d'exploitation de la tour eiffel
hadji nous avons réussi notre pari avec
bnl la tour eiffel remercie pnj la
france est quand même un dans le ravin
la tour eiffel remercie pn d'avoir
d'avoir permis de d'améliorer son image
notamment auprès des plus jeunes et
c'est donc ce groupe là qui est
disruptive vraiment incarné est un
chercheur en management cherche ce type
de terrain de terrain alternatif de
terrain pouvoir essayer de en essayant
de puiser des éléments des éléments de
compréhension des éléments pouvant être
transposée dans le monde l'homme dans le
monde dans le monde de la mode dans le
monde de l'entreprise
elle entra peur mais encore une fois
c'est le marseillais qui parle je suis
désolé je suis obligé de le citer
peut-être si je vais faire un signe vers
certains vont le reconnaître
le rappeur jul très décrié très décrié
ce rappeur évidemment il ne laisse pas
indifférent déjà ça c'est intéressant ce
rappeur à l'opposé de pnl qui fait
qu'ils ne communiquent jamais al'inverse
lui il est tout en bas
il est tout il sera un projet tous les
six mois un projet de 40 chansons main
sur un projet sur deux est gratuit il
est tout temps il répond il à une
stratégie de l'authenticité il répond à
ses fans qui lui laisse des messages sur
les réseaux sociaux sur les réseaux
sociaux on à l'opposé mais c'est une
stratégie tout à fait intéressante pour
des marques qui souhaitent fidéliser des
consommateurs on peut aller voir de ce
qui ce qui se fait de ce côté là un
rappeur comme sofiane j'en parlais tout
à l'heure dans ce no mi ser rendent en
grand dans le cercle
on a étudié avec les co auteurs on a
étudié le rendant le cercle et on a
décelé une capacité de leadership
phénoménal de ce rappeur sa capacité à
organiser la coopétition collaborent
c'est à dire que combinant coopération
et compétition que ce soit via son
émission vendant le cercle où son projet
qui s'appelle 93 empire ou l'arrêt ou la
réussite
excusez du peu a regroupé énormément de
groupes du 93
sachant qu'il ya plein de petites guéret
de plein de petites guéguerres on est
sur des vraies capacités de leadership
des choses dont on peut s'inspirer pour
le monde de l'entreprise des capacités à
faire travailler déjà ensemble à les
faire collaborer mais également les
faire entrer en compétition c'est
passionnant c'est passionnant de
s'intéresser à ça et enfin tous les
parcours entrepreneuriaux qui peuplent
le monde du rap en termes de projets on
peut parler des labels que ce soit on y
croit que ce soit d'une récolte ont ces
mecs sont partis de rien ces mecs ces
femmes et sénégal ils sont partis de
rien et qui ont surmonté les obstacles
qui ont réussi à apprendre à surmonter
les échecs à comprendre le langage des
banquiers de langage des comptables par
essai erreur en terme de parcours
entrepreneuriaux de table parcours
entrepreneurial pardon c'est passionnant
a étudié et on doit en tant que science
en tant que chercheur en sciences de
gestion qui se respecte on doit aller
essayé de puiser d'étudier ce qui se
passe là-bas mais une fois qu'on a dit
qu'on a dit tout cela on peut même
prendre un peu de recul
donc le rap peut inspirer le monde de la
sociologie the lady le monde de la
littérature
le rap est étudiée inspiré le monde de
l'entreprise mais quand on prend un peu
de recul
quand on s'intéresse à cette musique
réellement on peut même annoncer que le
rap et la musique qui a le mieux compris
notre société a l'air à l'ère de l'hyper
communication à l'ère du buzz du like du
partage à l'ère des communautés de
pratique à l'ère des communautés
d'intérêts le rap et la musique qui a le
mieux compris qui est le plus en phase
avec cela le rap sadap le rap évolue le
rabat parfaitement intégré l'un de la
nouvelle industrie musicale qui
fonctionne sur les stream sur la
rémunération via le streaming via le
streaming le rap et le plus en phase
avec notre société et avec avec notre
avec le avec notre temps donc la
prochaine fois que vous écouterez
durable posez vous la question qu'est ce
que cette musique on apprend sur moi et
sur la société qui m'entoure je pense
que vous serez pas déçus vous ne serez
pas déçus de la réponse et merci
[Applaudissements]